à tout et maintenant regardez regardez
bien ce disque se disent que c'est en
principe le disque de l'avenir un disque
numérique
inusable ou presque hinault rentrer en
contact avec aucun objet puisque c'est
un rayon laser qui le sillonnent il faut
pour cela un appareil adéquate en vente
depuis hier dans les magasins de ici
alors patrick esther vous dit tout sur
le disque numérique
cette fois pour entrer dans notre cadre
de vie familiale le microprocesseur
cette puce savante inventé par
l'électronique du 20e siècle a choisi
une voie originale la musique
cet appareil est l'un des tout premier
lecteur laser de disques numériques
l'apparition de ce matériel représente
un bouleversement profond dans le monde
de la musique et de la haute fidélité
plus que cela encore
c'est le symbole d'une nouvelle forme
d'industrie celle des technologies de
pointes appliqués aux loisirs
ce petit disque de 12 cm de diamètre
seulement permet l'enregistrement d'une
heure de musique d'où son nom de
compacts disques à côté de lui
le traditionnel 33 tours fait déjà
figure d'ancêtre avec la journaliste
classique une pointe frob dans le sillon
du disque et se met à vibrer en montant
et en descendant le long des boss du
sillon avec le compact disc le sillon
disparaît remplacé par des milliards de
minuscules trous percés suivant un code
numérique que seul
l'ordinateur peut analyser bien sûr ces
trous sont si petits qu'une aiguille ne
peut plus les lire n'utilise le faisceau
de lumière d'un laser
cette combinaison ordinateur laser
permet toutes sortes d'amélioration il
est par exemple possible de programmer
l'ordre dans lequel on désire écouter
les différentes chansons d'un disque
mais surtout cette combinaison lazer
ordinateur permet d'obtenir un relief
sonore digne des meilleures
installations professionnelles sans
aucun souffle et sans bruit de fond si
vous décidez de vous équiper
pas besoin de tout changer ses lecteurs
se branchent sur n'importe quelle chaîne
hi fi
une seule ombre au tableau le prix des
appareils de 6000 à 8000 francs un prix
très élevé qui semble-t-il ne devrait
pourtant pas empêcher l'explosion du
marché de ce nouveau système
nous pensons que le 33 tours
traditionnel disparaîtra dans une
dizaine d'années
c'est donc une révolution relativement
rapide quant aux prix actuels
bien entendu c'est un prix élevé mais ce
prix élevé nous avez enclin à une
certaine prudence
or l'exemple du japon montre que ce prix
élevé est tout à fait accepté par le
public l'avantagent produits étant
tellement décisif que le public estime
que le rapport qualité prix est quand
même très très favorable et le japon
vingt mille machines mis sur le marché
au mois d'octobre
toutes ces machines ont disparu en
quelques jours c'est vous dire si
l'accueil du public a été très favorable
par comment ça se passe et pour les gens
qui veulent une grosse discothèque de 33
tours
les éditeurs transféreront sur le
compact disc les anciens documents
sonores dont ils peuvent disposer par
conséquent on peut penser que la plupart
des mélomanes remplaceront
progressivement dans les années qui
viennent leur ancienne discothèque qui
était sous forme de micro sim
traditionnelle par du compact disc au
rythme de l'usure de leurs micro sillon
on fabrique ce disque exactement comme
des satellites ou des microprocesseurs
dans de vastes usines entièrement
blanche
habillés de combinaisons de vinyle
l'ennemi numéro un
la poussière ici on travaille au micron
près une seule poussière sur le moule et
ce sont des centaines de disques perdu
30% de ceux qui sortent de cette presse
partent pour la poubelle
et lorsque cette usine a démarré la
chaîne il y a quelques mois plus de la
moitié étaient inutilisables
c'est dire à quel point la production de
ces disques est une affaire délicate
paradoxe du progrès technique plus
l'objet à fabriquer petit plus il faut
une usine complexe est gigantesque
à ce jour trois usines seulement au
monde sont capables de produire ses
compacts disques la première en
allemagne un an
sur ces images la seconde au japon la
troisième aux etats-unis est en cours
d'implantation
al'inverse du magnétoscope le standard
du compact disc est international
standard unique qui amène aujourd'hui un
redéploiement mondial de l'industrie du
disque
cette usine des compacts disques a coûté
environ 90 millions de francs
naturellement c'est une somme que les
petites compagnies de disques ne peuvent
plus investir
seules les grosses compagnies peuvent se
le permettre et nous déjà nous sommes
prêts à nous à grandir et à passer à la
phase 2 c'est à dire investir encore 45
millions
cette nouvelle technologie risque donc à
terme de faire disparaître les petites
sociétés au profit de groupes très
puissants
la révolution technique du compact disc
n'est pas sans effet sur le plan social
les machines coûte tellement cher que
pour les amortir même cette usine qui ne
travaillait jusqu'ici avec deux équipes
vient d'instaurer les trois huit
une fois finie ce disque si délicat à
réaliser devient inusable inrayable la
musique qu'au départ l'ordinateur défie
le temps de nombreux chefs d'orchestre
contemporains ont compris la chance que
représente pour eux cette technique
herbert von karajan enregistre déjà
depuis plusieurs années en numérique
ainsi l'ordinateur permet aux
interprètes de devenir les égaux des
sculpteurs ou des peintres leurs oeuvres
pouvant enfin survivre à la mort et
c'est peut-être la plus belle
contribution du compact disc évacuation
ce matin a démis
les jeux vidéo sont partout surtout à
l'époque de noël à consommer sur place
ou à emporter à la maison
une constante le bruit
voilà maintenant un jeu plus classique
dans l'informatique mais tout à fait
remarquable parce qu'il intègre
énormément de choses
c'est jeu très mal c'était une série de
vue on peut programmer là c'est un coup
dur lui a sauté je doit accueillir avec
mon 1 karim fall sujet reste que je
change de jeu je retire le ne cire que
je mets la course de chevaux la mâchoire
et crispé le regard 6 les gestes
saccadés
les symptômes sont clairs le diagnostic
sans appel
ces enfants sont atteints d'un mal très
contemporain la passion des jeux vidéo
une enquête de la sofres réalisée auprès
de 250 enfants de 7 à 14 ans nous
apprend que la majorité d'entre eux est
m ainsi projetés dans un autre univers
surmonter les difficultés et surtout
réalisé des performances toujours
supérieure on peut la manche pas le bien
de faire de l' appariement tortora il
pourrait refaire sans dire c'est le
voilà il ya une espèce de compétition
avec soi-même ils veulent se vaincre
même ils veulent gagner ils veulent
réussir et à partir du moment où un
enfant veut réussir
évidemment il ya un dynamisme absolument
extraordinaires qui se fixent existant
lui et je trouve que c'est excellent
pour garder votre jeu et jouer plus tard
ou l'enregistrer sur les castes tout à
fait normal ça c'est vraiment
et alors ce poste vous le gardien jours
après l'émission ça c'est un rendez-vous
à demain
pip pour termites fait ce journal un bel
exploit sportif je pense que vous
connaissez tous ce cube dont il s'agit
de reconstituer toutes les faces c'est
ce qu'on appelle le rubik's cube
tout le monde ou presque est bien
aujourd'hui pour la première fois en
angleterre une compétition
époustouflante
écoutez le temps du vainqueur 39
secondes essayer de faire mieux a
londres ils étaient une centaine ce
matin à prendre part à l'épreuve de
vérité qui est le plus rapide à résoudre
les 43 milliards de milliards de
solutions du cube infernal de monsieur
rubik jamais casse tête n'a autant
mérité son nom erno rubik le père de ce
gadget diabolique n'a voulu même qu'un
chrono très moyen
une minute dix dans ses meilleurs jours
mais son cube lui apporte d'autres
compensations commercialisé à l'échelle
de la planète
le cube hongrois de monsieur rubik vaut
de l'or à 37 ans son inventeur et
célèbre très célèbre non seulement pour
avoir renfloué la balance commerciale de
son pays mais aussi pour avoir créé le
dernier jeu à la mode
le cube sécrète autour de lui des clubs
des t-shirts des publications et même
une maladie le cubique tombe le pouce du
pubis appelée ainsi par analogie avec le
tennis elbow
le jeu est donc devenu compétition et
commence même à voir sa légende des
bruits fou cours au sujet de japonais
ultra rapide qui leur constituerait en
13 secondes
ces jeunes anglais ont fait un peu moins
bien le vainqueur greg banner qui a 13
ans a mis trente neuf secondes et 2/10
moi j'ai réussi en dix minutes 30
pendant la durée du sujet
la folie du patin à roulettes qui gagne
aujourd'hui le centre de new york
avec au coeur de central park une piste
d'entraînement réservée aux patineurs
sur fond de musique disco bien
évidemment
et
m
il y aurait aujourd'hui 28 millions
d'américains qui seraient devenus des
adeptes inconditionnels de ce nouveau
sport mais
et
b
beke
officiellement on appelle ça le roller
skate mais on dit généralement le rôle
ère où le skate
alors restons français et parlons
simplement du patin à roulettes
il revient à la mode il revient en force
pendant la période de noël
il s'en est vendu comme des petits pains
on a retrouvé une paire de patins datant
de 1860
il ne s'agit donc pas d'une nouveauté
pour les enfants cela leur permet de
renouveler leur jeu de se dépenser
physiquement d'être en plein air un
bilan dont positif
des commerçants avisés ont ainsi dû
s'ouvrir des perspectives rentable
exemple ce dancing à la porte de paris
c'est le seul établissement de ce genre
existant actuellement en france
et ça marche ou plutôt ça roule alors
une mode
parions plutôt pour une nouvelle
activité de loisir une des rares notons
le au passage à ne pas consommer de
pétrole
depuis 18 mois environ on voit
des hommes et des dames aussi bien
qu'ils ont sur les oreilles un casque
leur permettant d'écouter la musique
même dans les bruits de la circulation
ce sont des walkman vous pouvez apporter
votre prochaine saison
emportez votre baladeur cassette depuis
cinq ans tous sont de plus en plus
nombreux dans le bus le métro ou la
russe casque aux oreilles et qu'à cet
âge fans à de rugueux jazz de saint bros
ils vivent dans nos maisons
pour les connaisseurs le lecteur de
cassettes stéréophonie est devenu
l'indispensable signe d'appartenance à
une certaine caste image de marque qu'il
véhicule et celle de l'action de la
jeunesse et du dynamisme
ils ont la sensation de pouvoir se
dégager tout ce qui est autour de soi de
pouvoir écouter la musique
s'extérioriser en soi même être bien moi
je les lis une invention qui enchante
surtout les vendeurs 1 millions
d'appareils vendus en france depuis un
an
son prix entre 800 et 1200 francs
une mode oui mais une mode peut être pas
sans conséquences il ne s'agit pas d'
éviter aux autres le bruit que l'on peut
faire mais de s'éviter à soit le bruit
et la présence les autres
pour les psychiatres c'est une nouvelle
rupture plus grave que celle des
générations alors ce danseur ou walkman
fait-il un pas en arrière ou un pas en
avant